Salut,
c’est Romain,
de 1000 idées de culture générale.
J’ai deux petites choses importantes
à vous dire
avant que la vidéo ne commence.
PREMIÈRE CHOSE :
ne regardez PAS
la vidéo
comme ça,
avec du pop-corn.
Si vous voulez RETENIR
ce que vous allez apprendre
dans cette vidéo,
vous DEVEZ
prendre des notes.
Les études sur la mémorisation
ne laissent AUCUNE PLACE
au doute :
NE PAS PRENDRE
DE NOTES
ÉGALE
OUBLIER.
Donc faites-moi plaisir :
ouvrez une application
comme Google Docs
ou Evernote,
et NOTEZ
ce qui est essentiel pour vous
au fur et à mesure.
SECONDE CHOSE
que je dois vous dire :
la vidéo que vous allez regarder
est extraite de ma formation
de culture générale
qui s’appelle
« Culture Express ».
C’est une formation qui permet
d’acquérir RAPIDEMENT
une bonne culture générale,
SANS
se prendre la tête,
sans avoir à lire
ni à réfléchir.
Elle couvre tous les domaines
de la culture générale :
elle permet de maîtriser
les connaissances essentielles
sur l’histoire de l’humanité,
sur l’histoire de France,
en économie,
en science politique,
en psychologie,
en science,
en littérature,
en art,
en religion,
ET ENFIN...
...en philosophie
— eh oui,
c’est important
la philo.
Si ça vous intéresse,
jetez-y un coup d’œil,
soit en cliquant
sur le lien qui apparaît maintenant
en haut à droite de la vidéo,
soit en cliquant
sur celui qui est dans la description
de cette vidéo.
Voilà voilà,
je vous ai dit
ce que je voulais vous dire.
Maintenant
je vous laisse regarder la vidéo.
Concentrez-vous,
préparez-vous
à prendre des notes,
et puis n’hésitez pas à m’écrire
dans les commentaires.
Et moi je vous dis :
à la prochaine !
________________
Qu’est-ce que la politique ?
« Tout est politique. »
— Slogan de Mai 68
Cette affirmation dépourvue de nuance inspire
la méfiance, mais l’idée derrière ce
slogan de Mai 68 — à savoir que la réalité
humaine est intégralement politique — cette
idée n’est pas impossible à défendre.
En effet, de nombreux exemples simples montrent
que la politique peut s’étendre à beaucoup
de choses : l’alcool au volant est devenu
un problème politique en Occident à partir
de la fin des Trente Glorieuses ; à la même
époque, les violences conjugales sont de
plus en plus perçues comme un problème de
société, alors qu’elles avaient longtemps
été considérées comme relevant de la sphère
privée ; autre exemple, la France fait partie
depuis 2019 de la cinquantaine de pays qui
ont interdit la fessée (qualifiée dans la
loi de « violence éducative ordinaire »). Ces
incursions de la politique dans la vie, y
compris intime, des citoyens peuvent donc
donner l’impression que « la politique
s’intéresse à tout », comme l’a écrit
Machiavel (la citation complète est d’ailleurs
« Tout n’est PAS politique, mais la politique
s’intéresse à tout »).
Après, les gens s’intéressent-ils à la
politique autant qu’elle s’intéresse
à eux ? Le slogan de Mai 68 est révélateur
de l’importance qu’a la politique à l’époque
: la tension idéologique de la guerre froide
et le développement de l’enseignement supérieur
décuplent l’intérêt des citoyens pour
les affaires publiques. Les idées de gauche,
en particulier, sont alors l’étendard de
la révolte contre l’ordre établi qui étouffe
la jeunesse.
Une telle politisation paraît aujourd’hui
révolue. À l’inverse, les observateurs
dénoncent l’individualisme de la société
de consommation, où chacun ne semble plus
concevoir son bonheur que dans le cadre étriqué
de sa sphère privée (en clair, les intérêts
personnels, la famille, les amis, et les relations
sentimentales). Les gourous du développement
personnel en font même un ingrédient du
bien-être : ne vous intéressez pas aux choses
que vous ne maîtrisez pas ; laissez donc
les affaires publiques de côté, et concentrez-vous
sur votre propre destin individuel. Ce conseil
n’est pas dénué de sagesse, mais qu’adviendra-t-il
d’une société dont les membres ne se sentent
plus concernés par le destin collectif ?
Dans cette leçon, je vais répondre aux questions
suivantes :
* Comment définir la politique ?
* Quelle est l’essence de la politique ?
* Quels sont les jalons de la pensée politique
?
* Qu’est-ce que la démocratie ?
* Qu’est-ce que la droite et la gauche ?
Comment définir la politique ?
Je vais d’abord vous donner une définition
générale du mot « politique » en partant
de son étymologie. Je préciserai ensuite
ses différentes dimensions.
Que signifie le mot « politique » ?
Le nom commun « politique » (qui est féminin)
vient du grec polis, qui signifie « la cité
», la communauté urbaine de l’Antiquité
grecque (dont le territoire et la population
étaient grosso modo de l’ordre de ceux
d’une ville moderne [Athènes, la cité
la plus brillante de l’Antiquité grecque,
comprenait environ 250 000 habitants au Ve
siècle avant J.-C.]). Du point de vue de
l’étymologie, la politique, ce sont donc
les affaires de la cité.
L’origine grecque du mot « politique » m’inspire
la définition à la fois la plus générale
et la plus simple : la politique, c’est
l’organisation de la vie collective.
Cette idée n’est pas compliquée, mais
je vous l’explique quand même en quelques
phrases. Comme on l’a vu dans le premier
module à propos des chasseurs-cueilleurs,
les hommes sont des « animaux » capables
de vivre en très grands groupes (comme une
nation) grâce à leur instinct de coopération
très développé. Seulement, une grande communauté
d’êtres humains n’est pas forcément
harmonieuse — les membres peuvent s’aimer
les uns les autres, mais ils peuvent aussi
bien se haïr et de se faire du mal.
« La méchanceté des hommes est sans limites.
»
— Aristote, Les Politiques
Autrement dit, la violence peut éclater au
sein du groupe, et ainsi menacer son existence
même — d’où la nécessité d’organiser,
et donc de pacifier les rapports entre les
individus afin de pérenniser le groupe. Et
organiser, cela signifie ordonner divers éléments
de manière à former un tout cohérent (c’est
dans cette perspective que l’on parle de
l’« ordre social »).
Bref, l’enjeu de la politique, c’est de
faire en sorte que les hommes réussissent
à vivre ensemble afin d’assurer la survie
du groupe. Et comme le répétait Alain Boyer,
mon prof de philosophie politique à la Sorbonne,
la politique, ça commence à l’échelle
du couple (il y a déjà un enjeu d’harmonie,
et donc d’organisation, quand on vit à
deux).
Quelles sont les différentes dimensions du
mot « politique » ?
Le mot « politique » est androgyne. Il est
la plupart du temps, dans la langue ordinaire,
féminin ; mais on l’emploie aussi parfois,
un peu avec snobisme, au masculin (vous pouvez
lire « le politique » sous la plume d’intellectuels
ou d’universitaires).
Dans le détail, le mot « politique » recouvre
trois dimensions. Le français utilise un
seul et même terme pour les trois, mais l’anglais
se sert de trois termes.
Voici les 3 dimensions :
1. LE politique (« polity » en anglais)
est le système politique dans son ensemble,
les structures institutionnelles et idéologiques
du pouvoir politique. Par exemple, si je dis
que « l’économie doit être soumise au
politique », cela signifie que c’est au
système politique, et non pas aux acteurs
eux-mêmes, de déterminer les modalités
de la production et de la répartition des
ressources dans la communauté. Les partisans
de cette thèse estiment que les inégalités
économiques mettent en péril l’harmonie
de la communauté, c’est pourquoi ils veulent
que le pouvoir politique contrôle l’activité
économique (c’est par exemple une des fonctions
de la fiscalité : elle redistribue les richesses
parmi les citoyens pour réduire les inégalités,
qui empoisonnent l’harmonie sociale).
2. LA politique (« politics » en anglais)
désigne la compétition politique, la lutte
pour la détention et l’exercice du pouvoir
politique. C’est par exemple dans ce sens
que l’écrivain Hemingway a dit « chacun
de mes contacts avec la politique m’a donné
l’impression d’avoir bu dans un crachoir
». Autant, d’un côté, il émane de la
noblesse DU politique, qui renvoie au fait
que la communauté maîtrise son propre destin
— autant, de l’autre, il n’est pas rare
que LA politique inspire le dégoût, parce
qu’à l’image du personnage principal
de la série House of Cards, les hommes ambitieux
qui s’engagent dans la compétition politique
abandonnent souvent la probité de l’homme
ordinaire pour parvenir au pouvoir (et pour
le conserver).
« La politique est l’art de mentir à propos.
»
— Voltaire
3. LES politiques (« policy », et « policies
» au pluriel, en anglais) désignent l’action
politique, plus précisément les programmes
d’action mis en place par une institution
pour atteindre des objectifs donnés. C’est
par exemple dans ce sens que l’on parle
des « politiques publiques », qui sont des
programmes d’action propres à une ou plusieurs
autorités publiques. Le singulier de cette
acception du terme « politique » est féminin
: on dit par exemple « UNE politique publique
». C’est encore dans ce sens que l’on
parle de LA « politique économique », qui
recouvre l'ensemble des interventions des
administrations publiques (dont notamment
l’État) dans l’économie. Enfin, par
extension, « une politique » est une orientation
générale suivie par une entreprise (la politique
de remboursement d’Amazon, par exemple),
ou même par un individu (qui peut suivre
la politique du moindre effort, par exemple).
Quelle est l’essence de la politique ?
Par « essence » de la politique, je veux
dire ce en quoi elle consiste fondamentalement,
son ressort essentiel, son principe élémentaire.
Il y a, à mes yeux, trois grandes réponses
de référence à cette question : celle d’un
philosophe de la Grèce antique, Aristote
(dans ses Politiques) ; celle d’un sociologue
allemand du tournant du XXe siècle, Max Weber
; et enfin celle d’un juriste allemand du
XXe siècle, Carl Schmitt.
Quelle est la réponse d’Aristote ?
Pour Aristote, l’essence de la politique
est dans la nature humaine.
Comme je vous l’ai expliqué dans la 2ème
leçon du module de culture philosophique,
Aristote définit l’homme comme « un animal
politique ». Autrement dit, il y a dans l’homme
un instinct politique, des dispositions innées
qui le déterminent à organiser la vie collective.
L’existence de cet instinct signifie que
l’homme est destiné par nature — puisque
la nature ne fait rien en vain — à s’associer
avec ses semblables dans le cadre de la cité.
Certes, reconnaît Aristote, il existe des
animaux grégaires (comme l’abeille), c’est-à-dire
des animaux qui vivent en groupe. Mais il
y a une différence essentielle entre l’homme
et ces animaux : l’homme, seul, possède
le langage. Or, cette faculté lui permet
d’avoir une compréhension bien plus profonde
de la réalité (il identifie par exemple
ce qui est profitable ou nuisible, ce qui
est juste ou injuste) ; puis elle lui permet
d’imaginer une nouvelle forme de réalité
humaine à travers une nouvelle configuration
de la vie collective. En clair, le langage
est si puissant pour décrire le monde qu’il
permet de le transformer.
Et à quoi bon transformer le monde en optimisant
l’organisation de la vie collective ? Parce
qu’il en va du bonheur, selon Aristote.
L’homme ne recherche pas seulement la société
de ses semblables pour surmonter sa condition
naturelle infirme, pour survivre ; il vit
en société parce que c’est comme cela
qu’il s’épanouit, qu’il est heureux.
« L’État, c’est la communauté du bien-vivre
et pour les familles
et les groupements de familles en vue du bonheur.
»
— Aristote, Les politiques
Sachez que la distinction établie par Aristote
entre, d’une part, l’homme qui serait
le seul « animal politique », et d’autre
part les autres animaux — cette distinction
est aujourd’hui remise en cause. Par exemple,
le primatologue Frans de Waal conclut de son
analyse des dynamiques sociales des chimpanzés
et des bonobos que les racines de la politique
sont plus anciennes que l’humanité. En
effet, le système de coalitions possibles
dans les sociétés des singes rend leur organisation
sociale très complexe.
Quelle est la réponse de Max Weber ?
Pour Max Weber, l’essence de la politique
réside dans l’autorité. L’ensemble des
conduites humaines qui comportent une domination
de l’homme par l’homme relèvent de la
politique. En clair, c’est l’aspect hiérarchique
de l’organisation de la vie collective qui
est primordial.
Et le cœur du problème, selon Weber, c’est
la légitimité : les dominés ne doivent
pas obéir simplement en raison de la contrainte,
mais parce qu’ils acceptent le commandement.
Par exemple, l’État français n’a plus
besoin de menacer les contribuables physiquement,
voire de les faire payer l’impôt de force
comme c’était parfois le cas sous l’Ancien
Régime, lorsque l’administration royale
voulait remplir les caisses. Même si tant
les principes que l’efficacité du système
fiscal français moderne — qui est un des
plus efficaces, sinon le plus efficace au
monde pour lever l’impôt — sont contestés,
l’immense majorité des contribuables consentent
à l’impôt et règlent d’eux-mêmes le
montant exigé.
« Toutes les dominations cherchent ainsi
à éveiller et à entretenir
la croyance en leur "légitimité". »
— Max Weber, Économie et société
Je vous expliquerai dans la leçon suivante
pourquoi et comment, selon Max Weber, à l’époque
moderne, l’autorité politique passe essentiellement
par l’État, et quels sont les types précis
d’autorité auxquels l’État peut recourir.
Quelle est la réponse de Carl Schmitt ?
Pour Carl Schmitt, l’essence de la politique
réside dans l’hostilité, plus précisément
dans la distinction de l’ami et de l’ennemi.
Carl Schmitt n’est pas d’accord avec les
penseurs de son époque qui assimilent le
politique à l’institution étatique. De
son point de vue, l’activité politique
est antérieure à l’État, qui n’en est
donc qu’une des expressions possibles. Dans
les faits, l’État n’a pas existé de
toute éternité — il est une création
de l’époque moderne, un instrument qui
a permis aux monarchies européennes, à partir
du XVIe siècle, de mettre fin aux guerres
privées afin de rétablir l’ordre dans
les limites de leurs territoires.
Pour Carl Schmitt, l’essence de la politique
consisterait donc plus fondamentalement dans
l’association et la séparation, à divers
degrés, des hommes (ce qu’on simplifie
en parlant de la distinction de l’ami et
de l’ennemi).
« La distinction spécifique du politique,
c’est la discrimination de l’ami et de
l’ennemi. »
— Carl Schmitt, La notion de politique
La dialectique de l’ami et de l’ennemi
se retrouve dans les apparences de l’activité
politique. Par exemple, le discours politique
privilégie souvent un vocabulaire qui se
rapproche de la rhétorique guerrière : les
campagnes, les affrontements verbaux, les
batailles d’opinion, le ton imprécatoire
dont usent les adversaires l’un à l’égard
de l’autre ressemblent à s’y méprendre
aux paroles qui précèdent les conflits armés.
L’activité politique semble donc se substituer
à une violence dont elle conserve les stigmates.
Par la discrimination de l’ami et de l’ennemi,
la politique évoque clairement le conflit
armé (qui repose sur la même discrimination).
Carl Schmitt retrouve donc l’idée de la
célèbre formule du théoricien militaire
prussien Clausewitz, selon laquelle la guerre
est « la continuation de la politique par
d’autres moyens ».
Quels sont les jalons de la pensée politique
?
Je vais d’abord vous parler de la naissance
de la pensée politique en Occident. J’évoquerai
ensuite comment cette pensée s’est libérée
de l’emprise de la religion chrétienne
à partir de l’époque moderne. Enfin, je
vous expliquerai la mutation de la pensée
politique en ce qu’on appelle la « science
politique » à partir du XIXe siècle.
Comment la pensée politique naît-elle en
Occident ?
La pensée politique naît en Occident sous
la forme de la philosophie politique.
Comme vous le savez, la philosophie occidentale
est née en Grèce — seulement, elle ne
s’intéresse pas immédiatement à l’organisation
de la vie collective. Cela change à partir
du Ve siècle avant J.-C. : avec la prédominance
d’Athènes, où triomphe la démocratie,
l’esprit des penseurs se tourne vers l’homme
lui-même. Les spéculations politiques ont
une place prépondérante dans l’effervescence
intellectuelle athénienne : on développe
la rhétorique pour imposer ses idées dans
l’opinion publique ; on compare les mérites
respectifs des régimes politiques et on imagine
des constitutions ; on réfléchit à l’essence
de la politique.
Nombreux sont les sophistes et les philosophes
de l’époque qui s’expriment sur le sujet,
mais — loi de Pareto oblige — seuls une
infime minorité sont devenus des références
de la pensée politique occidentale. Si les
idées de La République, l’utopie dans
laquelle Platon décrit l’organisation idéale
d’une société humaine (je vous en ai déjà
parlé dans la 2ème leçon du module de culture
philosophique, et le résumé détaillé est
disponible sur le site 1000 idées de culture
générale) — si les idées de La République
ont eu une grande influence sur la philosophie
occidentale, la pensée politique moderne
les laisse de côté parce qu’elles ne satisfont
pas l’idéal de la science moderne (elles
relèvent davantage de la littérature).
L’œuvre emblématique de la naissance de
la pensée politique en Occident, nous la
devons au disciple de Platon : ce sont Les
Politiques d’Aristote. Pour avoir lu La
République de Platon et Les Politiques d’Aristote,
j’ai été frappé par la différence — en
fait, cela n’a rien à voir. Le propos d’Aristote
est en bonne partie empirique, et il a une
rigueur scientifique : il justifie ses idées
; il compare plein de constitutions ; il évoque
de nombreuses lois ainsi que leur influence
sur l’harmonie sociale ; il fournit plein
d’exemples historiques (car à ses yeux,
tout groupe humain est le fruit d’une histoire
qui explique, entre autres facteurs, l’état
de ce groupe). Pour écrire une telle somme,
qui est un peu la bible politique de l’Antiquité,
Aristote a travaillé avec une équipe de
chercheurs qui a rassemblé beaucoup de matériaux
pour lui. Son objectif était d’écrire
un manuel pour former les futurs législateurs.
En effet, la philosophie politique grecque
n’était pas séparée de la pratique. Aristote
considérait la politique (en tant que discipline
intellectuelle) comme une science pratique,
c’est-à-dire qui guide l’action (d’où
le grand pragmatisme de son propos). Mais
le lien avec la pratique ne se limite pas
au réalisme du propos. Les philosophes grecs
confrontaient leurs idées à la réalité
en devenant conseiller des dirigeants (qui
les appelaient auprès d’eux). Par exemple,
Aristote a conseillé Alexandre le Grand (mais
c’est parce qu’il était son précepteur).
Platon lui-même, malgré l’irréalisme
de son propos, a été trois fois conseiller
— en vain — du tyran de Syracuse (d’abord
Denys l’Ancien, puis Denys le Jeune).
Comment la pensée politique s’émancipe-t-elle
de la religion ?
Le deuxième jalon est la laïcisation de
la réflexion politique. Au cours du Moyen
Âge, en effet, la pensée politique était
limitée par la prépondérance de la religion
et soumise à la théologie. Puisque Dieu
était le principe unique de l’ordre social,
il n’était pas nécessaire de chercher
à optimiser l’organisation de la vie collective.
Mais cette idée recule à partir du XVIe
siècle : c’est le fait de l’humanisme,
qui désacralise la pensée. L’auteur emblématique
de cette évolution est le philosophe italien
Machiavel (dont je vous ai déjà parlé dans
la leçon sur la philosophie du Moyen Âge
et de la Renaissance). Il théorise la politique
indépendamment de la doctrine catholique
et il fait preuve d’un grand réalisme (il
a été diplomate avant de se mettre à l’écriture).
Dans Le Prince (notamment), il énonce de
façon implacable les façons de gagner et
de conserver le pouvoir.
« Il faut estimer comme un bien le moindre
mal. »
— Machiavel, Le Prince
La laïcisation de la réflexion politique
progresse encore les siècles suivants :
* Dans la Prusse du XVIIe siècle, les sciences
camérales — le terme allemand « Kamera
» désignait le lieu où étaient conservés
les deniers publics — théorisent le gouvernement
de la société, et en particulier l’enrichissement
de la puissance publique. Comme je vous l’ai
expliqué dans la 3ème leçon du module de
culture économique, cette école de pensée
est animée par des hauts fonctionnaires qui
ont l’ambition de développer une science
de l’administration.
* Au XVIIIe siècle, les écrivains des Lumières
critiquent tant l’influence politique de
l’Église que le despotisme. Ils défendent
l’idée que la société doit être organisée
par les hommes eux-mêmes en vue de l’intérêt
général. Voltaire estime que cela passe
par la liberté et la tolérance, qui favorisent
la prospérité (il fait l’éloge du libéralisme
anglais dans ses Lettres philosophiques).
Pour sa part, Rousseau imagine carrément
de refonder la société sur de nouvelles
bases, un contrat social qui réussisse à
garantir à la fois l’égalité et la liberté
des citoyens.
* Enfin, la pensée politique occidentale
du XIXe siècle est marquée par deux nouvelles
perspectives : celle de Tocqueville, un Français
qui montre avec l’exemple américain que
la démocratie est plus qu’un régime politique,
qu’elle est une nouvelle société ; celle
de Marx, un intellectuel dissident prussien
qui avance que l’organisation de la vie
collective n’est pas déterminée par la
vie politique, mais par des facteurs plus
profonds, les rapports de force économiques.
Comment la science politique se constitue-t-elle
?
La discipline qu’on appelle la « science
» politique se constitue à partir du XIXe
siècle sous l’effet de deux évolutions
principales.
Sur le plan intellectuel, tout d’abord,
l’idéal de la science moderne — lequel
demande que l’on s’appuie sur des observations
rigoureuses et sur l’étude des faits afin
d’établir des lois — cet idéal transforme
la réflexion politique en élevant ses standards
de rigueur intellectuelle. Cette mutation
s’inscrit plus généralement dans le développement
des sciences sociales à l’époque. L’ouvrage
fondateur de la science politique telle qu’elle
est conçue de nos jours est le Tableau politique
de la France de l’Ouest (publié en 1913)
d’André Siegfried. Candidat malheureux
à la députation à plusieurs reprises, ce
prof de l’ancêtre de Sciences-Po tente
de rationaliser ses échecs en retraçant
les votes aux élections territoriales de
la France de l’Ouest. Ses conclusions (que
je vous explique dans la 4ème leçon du module)
se fondent sur la psychologie et la structure
de la propriété.
Sur le plan concret, ensuite, la démocratie
s’installe en Occident à la fin du XIXe
siècle. Élection après élection, la concurrence
est plus rude, ce qui fait naître une demande
d’expertise en matière politique. En France,
le juriste et journaliste Émile Boutmy fonde
l’École libre des sciences politiques,
l’ancêtre de Sciences-Po, à Paris en 1872.
Son ambition est, après le désastre de la
guerre contre la Prusse, de donner une culture
politique et administrative aux nouvelles
élites françaises en leur transmettant un
savoir davantage fondé sur l’expérience
et sur la pratique plutôt que sur les théories
juridiques (il ne voulait pas créer une nouvelle
école de juristes).
« La nouvelle école veut rendre l'élite
de la jeunesse française plus avisée, plus
sage,
moins exposée à être dupe des charlatans
politiques. »
— Émile Boutmy (dans une brochure de l’époque)
Sont créées à la même époque la London
School of Economics and Political Science
(qui est donc située à Londres, comme son
nom l’indique) en 1895 ; la Scuola « Cesare
Alfieri » di Scienze Sociali de Florence
en 1875 (Cesare Alfieri était un diplomate
italien renommé du XIXe siècle) ; ou encore
la School of Political Science de Columbia
(à New York) en 1880.
La science politique devient véritablement
une discipline universitaire autonome après
la Deuxième Guerre mondiale. Naissent alors
une association professionnelle, des revues,
un doctorat, et une agrégation qui donne
accès au corps des profs des universités.
Les centres académiques de la discipline
sont les Instituts d’études politiques
(Sciences-Po Paris, mais aussi les Sciences-Po
de province), les facultés de droit, d’autres
formations universitaires (en histoire et
en économie, notamment), et enfin aussi les
cours de sciences économiques et sociales
au lycée. Les spécialistes de la discipline
s’appellent les politistes. Par rapport
aux penseurs des périodes précédentes,
leur méthode est plus rigoureuse : ils se
servent de sondages, d’entretiens biographiques,
d’analyses comparées, d’observations
ethnographiques, ou encore de recueils statistiques.
Enfin, ce n’est pas très important pour
votre culture générale, mais vous pouvez
également retenir qu’on subdivise la science
politique en 4 domaines : 1° la théorie
politique ; 2° la sociologie politique (la
branche la plus importante) ; 3° la sociologie
de l’administration et des politiques publiques
; et 4° les relations internationales. Vous
l’avez compris, la sociologie est la source
intellectuelle principale — mais la science
politique puise aussi dans l’histoire, le
droit, la philosophie, ou encore l’économie.
Qu’est-ce que la démocratie ?
Je vais d’abord vous parler de la définition
de la démocratie (qui est assez problématique).
Je vous présenterai ensuite les différentes
formes de démocratie. Enfin, j’évoquerai
les principales limites de la démocratie,
qui sont mises en évidence dans les arguments
des critiques de ce régime politique.
Comment définir la démocratie ?
Le nom commun « démocratie » vient des
mots grecs demos, « le peuple », et kratos,
« le pouvoir ». À suivre l’étymologie,
la démocratie est donc l’organisation de
la vie collective dans laquelle le peuple
détient le pouvoir, c’est-à-dire qu’il
prend lui-même les décisions qui concernent
le destin de la collectivité.
Mais qu’est-ce que le « peuple » ? Issu
du latin populus, « peuple, ensemble des
citoyens », le peuple désigne l’ensemble
de la population d’un État, c’est-à-dire
tous ses citoyens — soit tous les individus
qui jouissent des droits civils et politiques.
Il y a une ambiguïté concernant la jouissance
des droits civils et politiques : les femmes
et les esclaves qui n’avaient pas le droit
de vote dans l’Athènes de l’Antiquité
faisaient-ils partie du peuple ? Les enfants
font-ils partie du peuple dans les démocraties
modernes ? On peut donc dire qu’il y a,
d’une part, le peuple au sens large, l’ensemble
de la population d’un État, comme dans
l’expression « le peuple français » ; et
d’autre part le peuple au sens précis,
c’est-à-dire tous les individus qui jouissent
des droits civils et politiques dans l’État,
comme dans l’expression « la consultation
du peuple ».
Ainsi, la démocratie est l’organisation
de la vie collective dans laquelle c’est
l’ensemble des citoyens qui décide du destin
de la collectivité.
Cette définition est proche de celle de la
célèbre formule d’Abraham Lincoln (le
président américain qui a aboli l’esclavage
en 1863), reprise dans l’article 2 de la
Constitution de 1958 de la Ve République
française :
« Le gouvernement du peuple, par le peuple,
pour le peuple. »
— Abraham Lincoln
Cette formule ajoute 2 dimensions qui ne sont
pas cruciales pour définir la démocratie
:
1. « le gouvernement DU peuple » : le pouvoir
politique, quelle que soit sa forme, consiste
forcément à diriger le peuple (puisque le
pouvoir « politique » est celui qui permet
d’organiser la vie collective) ;
2. « POUR le peuple » : le pouvoir politique
n’est pas forcément exercé dans l’intérêt
du peuple, mais comme l’a expliqué Aristote,
pour être légitime, le pouvoir politique
doit forcément viser « l’avantage commun
», autrement dit l’intérêt général
— l’idée que le pouvoir est exercé « pour
le peuple » est donc présupposée dans toute
forme de gouvernement qui se prétend légitime.
Par élimination, la locution cruciale de
la formule d’Abraham Lincoln est « par
le peuple ». La caractéristique fondamentale
qui définit la démocratie est donc que le
peuple soit lui-même aux commandes. Or, cela
pose un problème pratique : si un individu
unique peut prendre des décisions, comment
une multitude d’individus peut-elle y parvenir
? Faut-il forcément que tout le monde soit
d’accord pour considérer que le peuple
décide ? Ou bien suffit-il qu’une proportion
de la population soit d’accord ? Le fond
du problème — vous l’avez peut-être
compris — c’est que l’idée de « peuple
» fait passer une multitude d’individus
pour une entité unique, avec une volonté
unique, soit une entité dont on imagine qu’elle
pourrait prendre des décisions comme un individu
prend des décisions.
Ce problème demande de revoir la définition
de la démocratie :
* on peut corriger l’idée d’unité et
de totalité contenue dans la notion de peuple
par l’idée d’une proportion suffisante
de la population (en pratique la majorité)
;
* on peut corriger l’idée d’une direction
collective (qui paraît peu réaliste [même
si les potentialités d’internet changent
la donne]) par l’idée d’une direction
restreinte, c’est-à-dire d’un nombre
de dirigeants limité.
Avec ces révisions pragmatiques, la réalité
concrète de la démocratie ne correspond
pas à sa définition théorique. Pour Karl
Popper, la démocratie réelle se définit
par la capacité du peuple de choisir ses
dirigeants au moyen d’un scrutin majoritaire.
L’élection sert, dans cette perspective,
à faire changer le pouvoir de mains sans
violence. Elle représente une menace de destitution
qui incite les dirigeants à ne pas abuser
du pouvoir.
« La démocratie ne fut jamais le pouvoir
du peuple ;
elle ne peut pas l’être et ne doit pas
l’être. »
— Karl Popper, La leçon de ce siècle
Fondamentalement, il conçoit la démocratie
sous l’angle de la via negativa, c’est-à-dire
qu’il se concentre sur ce qu’il faut éviter.
La question essentielle à ses yeux est : comment
empêcher un dirigeant mauvais ou incompétent
de provoquer trop de dommages ?
En conclusion, vous pouvez retenir 2 définitions
générales de la démocratie :
1. la définition idéaliste : la démocratie
est l’organisation de la vie collective
dans laquelle c’est l’ensemble des citoyens
qui décide du destin de la collectivité
;
2. la définition réaliste : la démocratie
est l’organisation de la vie collective
dans laquelle la majorité des citoyens choisit
ses dirigeants.
Quelles sont les principales formes de démocratie
?
Les principales formes de démocratie consistent
en 3 distinctions.
1/ La distinction la plus importante oppose
les démocraties directe (1) et indirecte
(2).
(1) La démocratie est dite « directe » lorsque
le peuple gouverne directement, c’est-à-dire
sans intermédiaire. Elle correspond donc
à ce que j’ai appelé la définition « idéaliste
» de la démocratie, car c’est l’ensemble
des citoyens qui décide.
L’exemple emblématique est la démocratie
athénienne du VIe siècle avant J.-C. Sous
Périclès, l’homme politique associé à
ce régime, les citoyens se réunissent tous
les dix jours en assemblée (l’ecclésia)
pour discuter des affaires importantes et
voter les lois. Ils sont libres de proposer
des amendements sur les projets de loi et
leur temps de parole est équitablement réparti.
Périclès a également réformé le système
pour favoriser la participation des plus pauvres
ou de ceux vivant le plus à l’écart en
introduisant le misthos (« salaire »), une
indemnité journalière de présence.
« Nul n’est gêné par la pauvreté ni
par l’obscurité de sa condition sociale,
s’il peut rendre des services à la cité.
»
— Périclès, cité par l’historien Thucydide
dans La Guerre du Péloponnèse
Comme les citoyens athéniens sont tirés
au sort pour occuper les fonctions, ils ont
tous une chance égale de les occuper. Certains
d’entre eux sont ainsi magistrats et veillent
à l’exécution des lois ; d’autres sont
à l’origine des propositions de projets
de loi, et d’autres encore votent ces lois.
Cette participation à la décision ne concernait
toutefois qu’une petite minorité de la
population athénienne (environ 15 %) qui
possédait la citoyenneté, car les femmes,
les métèques et les esclaves en étaient
exclus. En outre, il était plus difficile
pour les ruraux et les plus pauvres de se
rendre au sein de la cité pour s’impliquer.
L’exemple moderne de démocratie directe
le plus connu est celui de la Suisse (même
si son régime est plutôt « semi-directe
»). En pratique, les citoyens élisent des
représentants aux différents conseils (à
l’échelon de la commune, du canton, et
de la Confédération) — ce qui rend le
régime en partie indirecte — mais les citoyens
peuvent aussi approuver des lois ou des modifications
de la constitution décidées par les conseils
(par le biais du référendum), ou encore
proposer eux-mêmes de nouvelles règles par
le biais de l'initiative populaire. Un exemple
qui a marqué les esprits hors du pays est
l’initiative populaire « contre la construction
de minarets » (les tours des mosquées),
qui a été approuvée à la fin 2009.
(2) La démocratie est dite « indirecte » (ou
représentative) lorsque les citoyens délèguent
le soin de gérer le destin collectif à des
représentants élus. Elle correspond donc
à ce que j’ai appelé la définition « réaliste
» de la démocratie, car le pouvoir décision
revient à une minorité restreinte de dirigeants
(choisis par la majorité des citoyens).
La plupart des grandes démocraties occidentales
sont indirectes. C’est par exemple le cas
de la Ve République française, même si
ce régime est en partie directe grâce à
l’outil du référendum prévu par l’article
3 de la Constitution de 1958.
« La souveraineté nationale appartient au
peuple qui l'exerce
par ses représentants et par la voie du référendum.
»
— Article 3 de la Constitution de 1958
2/ Une autre distinction importante oppose
deux types de démocratie indirecte.
Les politistes distinguent :
* Le régime parlementaire — Le parlement
prédomine, ce qui réduit le pouvoir de la
personne qui se trouve à la tête de l’État
(le roi dans une monarchie, le président
dans une république). Ainsi, ce régime favorise
le pouvoir législatif par rapport au pouvoir
exécutif (c’est par exemple le cas au Royaume-Uni
ou en Allemagne).
* Le régime présidentiel — La personne
qui se trouve à la tête de l’État a un
rôle important (le président américain,
par exemple). Ainsi, ce régime favorise le
pouvoir exécutif par rapport au pouvoir législatif.
J’approfondirai cette distinction dans la
leçon sur les régimes politiques.
3/ Enfin, une autre distinction oppose les
démocraties populaire et pluraliste.
La démocratie dite « populaire », ou « réelle
», est le modèle démocratique des régimes
d’inspiration marxiste (essentiellement
l’URSS et la Chine). L’idée qui transparaît
dans le nom est que ce modèle est, lui, véritablement
connecté au peuple, en vertu de quoi il est
fidèle à l’idéal démocratique. Cette
prétention découle de la critique de la
démocratie existante par Karl Marx : il la
qualifie de démocratie « bourgeoise », car
il s’agit en réalité — à ses yeux — d’une
organisation de la vie collective imaginée
par la classe dominante (la bourgeoisie) pour
imposer sa domination. La prétendue égalité
et les prétendus droits politiques des prolétaires
sont de la poudre aux yeux : ils n’empêchent
pas les capitalistes d’exploiter les ouvriers
comme des esclaves dans les usines. Seulement,
dans les faits, la dimension démocratique
des régimes d’inspiration marxiste est
douteuse : pas de partis, pas d’élections
pluralistes, et des dirigeants qui justifient
la légitimité de leurs décisions en les
disant conformes au sens commun du peuple.
La démocratie dite « pluraliste » se caractérise
par la coexistence de diverses opinions dans
le débat politique, ce qui se traduit au
niveau institutionnel par l’existence de
divers partis qui sont en concurrence pour
accéder au pouvoir. Les démocraties qui
appartenaient au bloc de l’Ouest lors de
la guerre froide étaient pluralistes. Un
fait illustre leur différence par rapport
aux démocraties populaires : il existait
des mouvements communistes dans les systèmes
politiques occidentaux (même s’ils ont
parfois subi l’oppression de ces systèmes,
comme cela fut le cas aux États-Unis avec
le maccarthysme au début des années 1950)
; en revanche, aucun mouvement politique ne
pouvait se réclamer des démocraties capitalistes
dans les démocraties populaires.
Quelles sont les limites de la démocratie
?
La démocratie nous apparaît aujourd’hui
en Occident comme une évidence. Elle serait
le meilleur régime politique, le seul véritablement
légitime — au point que certains, comme
Jacques Attali, affirment ouvertement que
toute thèse qui remet en cause la démocratie
n’a plus sa place dans le débat public.
Cette confiance en la démocratie tend à
réduire les critiques au silence, mais cela
n’atteint pas le bien-fondé de certaines.
Voici, en synthèse, les principaux arguments
contre la démocratie :
* L’incompétence du peuple — La démocratie
présuppose que le peuple, c’est-à-dire
l’ensemble des citoyens, puisse prendre
de bonnes décisions. Or, cela est douteux.
Platon stigmatisait déjà dans La République
l’irrationalité du peuple, animé par l’apparence,
le préjugé et la passion ; et il l’opposait
à la rationalité du philosophe, lui armé
de la connaissance du vrai et de l’expérience.
Les politistes américains de la seconde moitié
du XXe siècle parleront de l’« incompétence
politique » de l’électeur, qu’ils quantifieront
grâce aux sondages. Le fait que Hitler soit
parvenu au pouvoir en Allemagne en ayant remporté
les élections législatives de 1932 est souvent
invoqué pour illustrer la faillibilité de
la démocratie.
« Le meilleur argument contre la démocratie
est
une conversation de cinq minutes avec l'électeur
moyen. »
— Winston Churchill
Certains partisans de la démocratie rétorquent
que le peuple peut être compétent, mais
qu’il est maintenu dans l’incompétence
par les élites. Noam Chomsky avance par exemple
dans Comprendre le pouvoir que si l’électeur
moyen s’intéressait au jeu politique comme
il s’intéresse à son sport favori — c’est-à-dire
en y consacrant du temps et sans ressentir
le syndrome de l’imposteur — alors il
aurait un avis éclairé.
* La démagogie — L’incompétence (pour
parler poliment) du peuple et le fait qu’il
obéisse à l’émotion plutôt qu’à la
raison — cela favorise un certain type d’hommes
politiques, les démagogues. Issu des mots
grecs demos, « le peuple », et agogos, « qui
guide, qui attire », la démagogie est le
fait de séduire le peuple, considéré le
plus souvent sous la forme d’une foule,
en lui disant ce qu’il a envie d’entendre.
En clair, il s’agit de manipuler la masse
en jouant sur ses ressorts émotionnels, plutôt
que de lui dire la vérité et de lui proposer
des solutions réalistes et efficaces. La
désignation de boucs émissaires (les étrangers,
les pauvres, les riches, etc.) est par exemple
un ingrédient typique d’un discours démagogique.
* L’impossibilité pratique — Comme je
l’ai déjà évoqué, l’idéal démocratique
— que le peuple participe activement et
directement au pouvoir — paraît difficile
à réaliser. Il y a plusieurs difficultés
pratiques à ce que le grand nombre gouverne
(telles que la réunion des citoyens, l’enregistrement
des décisions ou encore la fréquence des
prises de décision). C’est pourquoi, dans
les faits, c’est toujours le petit nombre
qui gouverne (c’était d’ailleurs déjà
le cas dans la démocratie directe athénienne).
« Il est contre l’ordre naturel que le
grand nombre gouverne et que le petit soit
gouverné.
On ne peut imaginer que le peuple reste incessamment
assemblé
pour vaquer aux affaires publiques. »
— Rousseau, Du contrat social
* L’inefficacité — Comme je vous l’ai
expliqué en définissant la démocratie,
elle tire sa légitimité du fait que le pouvoir
politique émane du peuple (c’est le sens
de la locution « par le peuple »). Elle
ne tire donc pas sa légitimité, en tant
que régime politique, de sa haute capacité
à résoudre les problèmes. Au contraire,
même, elle tend à sacrifier l’efficacité
à la légitimité. En favorisant le débat,
la limitation des pouvoirs, le contrôle,
la révision voire l’annulation des décisions,
elle peut accoucher de l’impuissance. Dans
les faits, l’ampleur du problème varie
selon les modalités de fonctionnement du
régime démocratique. Par exemple, la IVe
République française (qui a duré de 1946
à 1958) représente une forme d’impuissance
démocratique due aux incessants revirements
d’alliance entre les partis, tandis que
la Ve République a été imaginée par le
général de Gaulle précisément pour dépasser
cette impuissance.
* La dérive oligarchique — Cet argument
consiste à dire que, dans la démocratie
représentative, les représentants oublient
progressivement qu’ils sont censés traduire
la volonté des représentés et agir dans
l’intérêt des représentés ; ils en viennent
alors à former une petite classe de dirigeants
qui monopolisent le pouvoir politique et l’exercent
dans leur propre intérêt. La démocratie
représentative muterait donc en une oligarchie,
c’est-à-dire une forme de gouvernement
où un petit nombre de personnes détiennent
l’autorité. Le controversé militant politique
français Étienne Chouard, qui est un des
partisans les plus actifs de la démocratie
directe, affirme que le concept de la démocratie
représentative est un oxymore dans la mesure
où la représentation empêche le peuple
de décider par lui-même. Il voit dans le
tirage au sort la solution qui empêche la
démocratie de dériver en oligarchie.
Qu’est-ce que la droite et la gauche ?
Je vais d’abord vous raconter l’origine
historique du clivage droite-gauche et de
sa diffusion dans le monde. Je vous expliquerai
ensuite comment son sens idéologique a évolué
jusqu’à aujourd’hui. Enfin, j’étudierai
la question de savoir si le clivage droite-gauche
est toujours pertinent en m’intéressant
aux arguments des deux côtés du débat.
Quelle est l’origine historique du clivage
droite-gauche ?
Le clivage droite-gauche naît lors de la
Révolution française.
Il s’explique précisément par la localisation
des partis politiques dans l’assemblée
des états généraux de 1789, en particulier
lors des débats concernant le poids de l'autorité
royale par rapport à l'assemblée populaire
dans la future constitution. Les partis soutenant
le roi (composés majoritairement de nobles
et d’hommes d’Église) sont alors situés
à droite du président de l’assemblée.
Ce sont les places d’honneur, car le côté
droit a une valeur positive dans la culture
occidentale (l’adjectif « droit » qualifie
par exemple un individu qui respecte les règles
de la morale [on parle aussi de la « droiture
morale »]) — en revanche, le côté gauche
a une connotation péjorative (l’adjectif
« gauche » signifie par exemple « maladroit
»). À gauche du président de l’assemblée,
on trouve donc les partis qui veulent abolir
l’ordre monarchique (composés d’individus
du tiers état).
Ce clivage a perduré dans les assemblées
françaises après la Révolution, car le
pays a longtemps hésité entre la république
et la monarchie. Il a été particulièrement
sensible lors de la Restauration (1814-1830),
lorsque la France est redevenue monarchique
à la fin de l’Empire napoléonien : les
partisans du roi étaient toujours à droite
; à gauche, on trouvait les héritiers de
la Révolution française ainsi que ceux de
l’Empire napoléonien. À la fin du XIXe
siècle, les partis politiques se créent
à partir de ce clivage.
Le clivage s’est ensuite répandu hors de
France. La grande influence de la Révolution
française a entraîné la transplantation
de la division droite-gauche dans les assemblées
des autres pays d’Europe, et même en Russie,
au XIXe siècle. Au Royaume-Uni, par exemple,
les partis conservateurs et libéraux sont
les héritiers des tories et des whigs qui
s’opposent depuis le XVIIe siècle (au cours
duquel ont eu lieu les deux révolutions anglaises)
sur la question des pouvoirs respectifs du
roi (les tories sont les partisans du roi)
et du Parlement (dont les whigs demandent
le renforcement). Le clivage révolutionnaire
français s’est même imposé en Amérique
(même s’il n’a pas le même sens idéologique
aux États-Unis) ; puis dans les pays décolonisés
au XXe siècle.
Quel est le sens du clivage droite-gauche
?
En France, son sens a progressivement évolué
depuis la Révolution française : il s’est
déplacé sur de nouvelles questions.
Sur le plan historique, le clivage droite-gauche
a eu 3 sens différents :
1. Lors de la Révolution française, comme
je viens de vous l’expliquer, le clivage
porte sur la question du pouvoir politique
du roi dans le nouveau régime. La droite
souhaite que le roi continue de peser dans
les décisions (notamment par l’intermédiaire
d’un droit de veto), tandis que la gauche
s’y oppose.
2. Depuis grosso modo la seconde moitié du
XIXe siècle, le clivage se déporte sur la
question du rapport entre l’État et l’Église.
La droite est animée par les catholiques,
qui souhaitent le maintien de l’influence
de l’Église dans la société française,
tandis que la gauche est animée par les partisans
de la laïcité, qui obtiendront notamment
la séparation de l’Église et de l’État
par la loi du 9 décembre 1905.
3. Depuis grosso modo l’entre-deux-guerres
(mais le déplacement a commencé avec la
révolution industrielle au XIXe siècle),
le clivage se porte désormais sur la dimension
économique de l’organisation de la société.
La droite est principalement capitaliste et
opposée à l’intervention de l’État
; la gauche, quant à elle, est critique du
capitalisme et favorable à l’intervention
de l’État (des hommes politiques keynésiens,
comme Dominique Strauss-Kahn par exemple,
sont classés à gauche). On peut ajouter
qu’un clivage culturel se surajoute au clivage
économique grosso modo depuis la révolution
culturelle des années 1960 : les partisans
de la libération (ou libéralisation) des
mœurs sont à gauche, les opposants sont
à droite. La question du mariage homosexuel
(légalisé en 2013) a illustré ce clivage
culturel.
« Je n’aime pas les riches. »
— le candidat socialiste François Hollande
lors de la campagne présidentielle de 2012
François Hollande n’a pas été un président
révolutionnaire, ni même gouverné à la
gauche de la gauche, mais cette déclaration
était un marqueur idéologique fort.
Est-il possible de synthétiser ces différents
sens dans un clivage fondamental ?
Sur le plan philosophique, on peut dire que
le clivage droite-gauche porte essentiellement
sur la question de la nature de l’ordre
social. La droite pense que l’ordre social
est naturel, c’est-à-dire que l’organisation
de la société doit suivre des règles préexistantes
(qui relèvent de l’ordre des choses, comme
la gravité ou les saisons) ; la gauche pense,
elle, que l’ordre social est artificiel,
c’est-à-dire que ce sont les hommes eux-mêmes
qui imaginent les règles de l’organisation
de la société (toute utopie est donc par
définition de gauche). L’ordre naturel
est souvent assimilé à la tradition (au
sens de l’imitation des générations passées),
et ses partisans sont les conservateurs. L’ordre
artificiel est souvent assimilé à la raison
(qui amène à douter et à améliorer), et
ses partisans sont les progressistes.
La distinction entre l’ordre naturel et
l’ordre artificiel permet même de comprendre
le sens des extrêmes : l’extrême droite
est ultra-conservatrice (d’où, par exemple,
sa défense de la pureté ethnique, ou encore
le projet nazi de revenir aux valeurs des
prétendus ancêtres antédiluviens des Allemands,
les Aryens) ; l’extrême gauche est, elle,
révolutionnaire, elle imagine rebâtir la
société sur des bases nouvelles.
Le clivage droite-gauche est-il dépassé
?
Pour faire simple, je vais vous présenter
3 arguments en faveur de la thèse selon laquelle
le clivage droite-gauche est dépassé ; puis
3 arguments contre cette thèse. Je me concentre
sur la situation de la France (disons depuis
la fin des Trente Glorieuses), parce qu’il
serait bien trop compliqué de répondre à
la question pour une multitude de pays.
Le clivage paraît dépassé pour les raisons
suivantes :
1. L’avènement d’une société de classes
moyennes réduit les tensions politiques.
Il se traduit par l’émergence d’un gros
bloc majoritaire de citoyens dont le souci
principal est de préserver leur confort quotidien
— en cela, ils sont conservateurs — tout
en garantissant le progrès continu de leur
bien-être — en cela, ils sont progressistes.
Telle est la thèse développée par l’ancien
président de la Ve République française
Valéry Giscard d’Estaing en 1984 dans Deux
Français sur Trois : l’opposition de la
droite et de la gauche n’a plus de valeur
dans une société dominée par la classe
moyenne, c’est pourquoi il faut « gouverner
au centre ».
2. Le clivage idéologique majeur serait désormais
la mondialisation (entendue au sens principalement
économique). Une partie des Français — et
plus généralement des citoyens en Occident
— consentent à l’accélération des flux
de marchandises, de capitaux et d’hommes
qui a cours depuis les années 1980, et qui
rend notamment plus difficile d’organiser
la vie collective à l’échelle de la nation.
Ces citoyens sont schématiquement représentés
par le centre ainsi que par les ailes modérées
de la droite et de la gauche. L’autre partie
des citoyens rend la mondialisation (et souvent
aussi l’Union européenne) responsable des
malheurs de la société (elle dénonce par
exemple les délocalisations, la perte de
souveraineté nationale, ou encore l’immigration
de masse). Elle est schématiquement représentée
par les partis extrêmes (de plus en plus
qualifiés de « populistes »), ainsi que
par ce qu’on appelle « la droite de la
droite » et « la gauche de la gauche ».
« La mondialisation consiste à fabriquer
des esclaves pour vendre à des chômeurs.
»
— Marine Le Pen
3. Le développement de la technocratie, c’est-à-dire
le fait que le pouvoir soit exercé par des
experts qui fondent leurs décisions sur des
données techniques plutôt que sur leur sensibilité
idéologique — cette évolution contribuerait
à mettre le clivage droite-gauche à l’arrière-plan.
Ainsi, il n’y aurait plus les idées de
droite et les idées de gauche, mais les solutions
qui fonctionnent et celles qui ne fonctionnent
pas. Dans les faits, les gouvernements semblent
de moins en moins partisans : Nicolas Sarkozy
avait innové en 2007 en nommant des « ministres
d’ouverture » (le plus emblématique étant
probablement le socialiste Bernard Kouchner,
au ministère des Affaires étrangères) ; François
Hollande, lui-même énarque, a mis en place
des gouvernements particulièrement technocratiques
; enfin, Emmanuel Macron, qui se dit pourtant
de gauche, a donné des ministères à des
hommes politiques de droite.
Voici maintenant les raisons pour lesquelles
le clivage paraît toujours pertinent :
1. Le poids de l’État dans l’économie
française fait perdurer le clivage droite-gauche
sur la question de l’interventionnisme : la
gauche est pour, la droite contre. Le paramètre
de la fiscalité est emblématique à cet
égard : d’un côté, la droite dénonce
« l’enfer fiscal » français ; de l’autre,
la gauche dénonce la triche et l’optimisation.
2. Le prolongement de la libération des mœurs
qui a commencé dans les années 1960 fait
perdurer le clivage culturel. La gauche (dite
« libertaire ») est favorable à ce que
l’organisation de la vie collective s’adapte
aux nouveaux modes de vie ainsi qu’à la
diversité des identités individuelles ; la
droite s’oppose au bouleversement des modèles
traditionnels (en particulier celui de la
famille).
3. Ce dernier argument est un peu plus technique.
Si le clivage droite-gauche est peut-être
moins pertinent au niveau de l’« offre
politique » — ce que proposent les hommes
politiques — il demeure en revanche pertinent
au niveau de la « demande politique », c’est-à-dire
au niveau des croyances et des souhaits des
électeurs. Les enquêtes du CEVIPOF (le Centre
de recherches politiques de Sciences Po) de
la fin des années 2010 montrent que moins
de 10 % des citoyens français ne savent pas
dire s’ils sont de droite ou de gauche,
et que ce positionnement idéologique est
un marqueur profond de l’identité sociale
d’un individu.
________________
Alors,
la vidéo vous a plu ?
J’espère que oui.
Je vous rappelle
que c’est un extrait
de ma formation de culture générale
« Culture Express ».
Si vous voulez en savoir plus,
cliquez sur le lien
qui apparaît maintenant
en haut à droite de la vidéo,
ou bien
sur celui qui est dans la description
de cette vidéo.
Voilà voilà,
comme d’habitude
n’hésitez pas à m’écrire
dans les commentaires,
et puis SURTOUT
N’OUBLIEZ PAS
que vous n’avez PAS BESOIN
de vous prendre la tête
pour vous cultiver.